mais ça
le musée nous a prêté des cadres dorés
qui avaient des toiles de grands maîtres
en fait et nous ce qu'on a voulu c'est
de refaire des petites scènes avec des
animaux et de reprendre des végétations
bien sûr en travaillant sur le collage
et le découpage seulement est ce qu'on a
voulu c'est que ces enfants là au lieu
de repartir directement avec leurs
petites oeuvres qu'ils participent à une
petite exposition
voici là c'est en quoi il ya des enfants
qui ont travaillé aussi enfance étaient
des jumeaux par exemple qui ça
non mannion qui va pleurer le lion va fé
en fait c'est un cerf vue des coupes
propre roman et c'est la dame peut nous
dit qu'est ce qu'on voit
le roi de la savane et gestion des
sondés comme tu ne laisses et des nuages
cours en papier après si tout ça change
un petit peu des activités pédagogiques
on sent poindre
c'est bien on va leur demander à eux en
tout cas ils ont l'air d'être captivé
les fans du plaisir ils sont n'aurait
pas demandé encore mais ils ont l'air
d'être intéressé est captivé par par
l'activité